Um, all right, let's check in with our caller
from the five, seven, four area code.
Who is calling today from five, seven four.
Hi David.
Thanks for taking my call.
My name is Andre big fan of the channel.
Um, so a couple of days ago you had a caller
that called in and talked about the BP [inaudible]
with uh, Bernie potentially getting nominated.
And you guys talked about policy being a pic
and you mentioned that she would be a terrible
pick.
Can you expand on that and explain why you
think that would be the case and what would
be from your ideal VP picks for a Burton tickets?
Yeah, so listen, we don't need to re adjudicate
Tulsa's entire platform, but, um, I, although,
you know, it's very often said Tulsi endorsed
Bernie 2016.
So their politics are the same.
They're not, they're very different.
Their foreign policy views are different.
Their positions on, um, uh, healthcare, our
OSB found out are very different.
So, you know, I want Bernie's VP to be someone
not who is going to maybe appeal to some,
a few Republicans in the way that Tulsi does
or whatever.
I, I really want someone who's committed to
the same progressive platform or very close
to it that Bernie Sanders is now as far as
who would be a good VP choice for Bernie Sanders.
Honestly, I'm not thinking about it yet and
I, I could not, I'm not prepared to give any
names.
I know people have called in and they floated
a few different names.
A lot of people call in and say, what about
Bernie Warren together?
I don't know.
I mean right now, not even a single vote has
been cast in the democratic primary.
So I'm not really exploring that yet.
I'm looking at other things right now, but
I'm confident that Bernie, uh, will evaluate
a variety of choices.
And I believe that he ultimately, I could
be wrong, but I believe he's ultimately going
to choose someone who's highly aligned with
his politics rather than sort of from a different
wing of the democratic party.
But I could be wrong.
Okay.
That makes sense.
Can I, can I do one more follow up?
Um, so, uh, recently in the news, uh, the
ruling came down that, uh, the Trump tax returns
would have to be turned over for the investigators
and there's a high likelihood of it being
challenged in the Supreme court.
Do you think the Supreme court will take,
uh, we'll take up, uh, the decision on that
and if, uh, if they do side with Trump, um,
what kind of damage do you think that's gonna
do to the institution of the Supreme court?
So here's the thing.
I assume the Supreme court, if they take it
up, we'll side with Trump and that the tax
returns won't be given to investigators.
But here's the thing, we are like 360 days
from the election, right?
At this point in time, um, the, I, I still
believe that the most effective way to get
Donald Trump out in the quickest is just to
defeat him at the ballot box in November of
2020.
Cause we're under a year away.
So, uh, Trump it, even if the tax returns
were turned over to investigators, that doesn't
mean that they're going to the house of representatives.
It doesn't mean that they're going public.
So I am trying to take a pragmatic approach,
which is Donald Trump's Supreme court, a Supreme
court that is increasingly a made up of conservative
justices and justice is selected by Trump,
is unlikely to do what we want them to do
when it comes to Trump's taxes.
Even if they said they've gotta be released
to investigators, the investigators don't
make them public, they might leak.
So I think we don't even worry about it and
we just vote the guy out in 360 days.
Yeah, absolutely.
I was just asking more from the standpoint
of not necessarily getting them out, but setting
a precedent.
Uh,
Oh, I mean, listen the, the precedent that
the Supreme will say when they decide that
Donald Trump doesn't have to turn over to
the tax returns, if that's what they do, we'll
be that checks and balances effectively no
longer matter because the president decides
who chooses whether the checks and balance
is still applied.
So it will be extraordinarily damaging.
It will be extraordinarily damaging, but we
can still vote them out in under a year.
But, and that's why they feel so comfortable.
Just ignoring a little bit the subpoenas that
are coming down the investigation.
Absolutely.
There's been no evidence so far that we'll
be holding out.
Thanks so much.
Thank you.
Appreciate it.
Yep.
Hope to hear from you again.
That does it for today.
Sorry to everybody that I didn't get to and
I do see their fifth year, 55 people.
Uh, hopefully next time we will take calls
again